all right cool cool make it harder
difficulty thank you hard hey I gotta go
get a drink oh my god oh man
private co-op wait now you left us yeah
uh guys guess how far I went to give my
my drink how far three 3 feet I went to
my mini fridge oh oh [ __ ] is it in your
office hey now weights the only loser
who doesn't have a mini fridge in his
office I do it's just up right outside
my office
Wade you grubby bit you [ __ ] come on I
can't believe you just take it without
even considering our feelings oh I
didn't it was easy well I'll take this
then I'm going off on my own apparently
yeah all right bye cuts around the bend
all right oh there's a claw look I don't
care about your sexual fetishes oh and
that's death I'm gonna cut through the
claw water corner death room yeah you
would you pervert you sexual deviant run
[Music]
you okay so far so good all right Oh
goodbye boot that way what is that what
you want huh wait for me guys I got
sorry what is this that's the way down
oh yeah I did not go down oh I get the
ceiling hey Bob look for you a shoe see
I'm not so greedy as Keanu now am I
you're still a hole guys I'm gonna go
I'm gonna face the dragon I can tell
this is my challenge this is this room
this is my destiny there's alligators
I'm okay
Oh jump yes on the best yeah I'm good
dude I'm good yeah you eat whatever
you're eating okay it's not that we keep
the door open I don't how do I do that
oh hey I only have one bandage oh you
want it you want it you want it no oh
how the [ __ ] did you even do that how do
you drop them there's only one item the
prison is definitely good
being blown everywhere dude tell me
about it all right Papa's happy room
over here oh holy [ __ ]
are you talking about
we found a fun room and Wade was a [ __ ]
and do one do it
that seems like this looks like a Marc
kind of room
right right right you're right you're
right man no [ __ ] given huh yeah that's
[Music]
chill is it yeah I mean I'm in a good
place except for the all the damage I
took okay cool that was my own fault as
much as anything else chains where did
Wade go I'm right across the way if you
guys open the door over there hey so I
saw you doing Kiowas over there oh why
don't you know how we point when you
left click yeah
if one of us goes in one of these death
rooms and you guys are around to watch
it if you left click you'll salute us oh
I don't believe you you gotta prove that
we are killing it this room I feel like
Marc Marc safety safety Oh God what do
you mean safe
my ankles it was they say no this room
is safe look I am trying to find Dirk
all the rooms that we need to go I'm
trying to find the exit you're trying to
find oh where are you i'm south of one
of you oh I'm right here
buddy wait for me wait guys gonna
bandage up real quick
Skoosh bandages are for [ __ ] well
that's why I don't have any you do say
it's not safe guys are missing out on
the ultimate safe route I'm destroying
this with my safety oh dude it's shy big
three in a row safe perfectly safe ah no
wait let me in I am the goddamn master
no danger I'm gonna veer off this path
don't ah
wait yes dude - there's do I feel like I
feel like - me yeah I know right here
yeah come on yeah see no me first me
first me first me first
holy [ __ ] no problem whatever I'm blind
I don't need to see stop Oh No
[Applause]
[Music]
reckless abandon yeah I don't think we
should have this much reckless abandon
Bob reckless upping bad that's trap oh I
open that one that's not a good one I'm
gonna go to the marker there was a
bandage no no that's not a good room why
can't I why why hey okay I got it
totally worked out God why does wait
always find it ohayo through this
[ __ ] room on the other side oh right
go right go right I'm going right I'm
doing what you said
I am moving on like a genius
[ __ ] what snippers oh I'm this kind
of dead you guys want to come watch this
it's pretty fun
make it salute you salute me please
please God okay I'm trying wave you
promise me you promise I promise you oh
thank you okay well all right I gotta
make a riskless too reckless Oh Oh God
all right I'm out of shoes here we go oh
you're totally fine no nice Chuck dude
thanks man thank you that seemed fine
that seems fine that's fine that's good
oh it's fine it's fine fine yeah just
try to just keep going all right fine
[ __ ] yes oh yes I feel good about
this mark welcome back to the world okay
wait get over here
would you could you I'm working my way
up wait come on would you on a plane
could you would you up we are not down
oh no we're up a floor you stupid
tricked me I was heading up and you
needed me to go down okay who's got
shoes I got shoes bro I got you Hey look
mark or two Hey all right mark wizard
please it means it's safe right this
means it's safe
I don't know it's safe means anymore Oh
God oh boy
I don't want to go oh god oh god you
were safe were safe
Oh Oh Oh God hey bud
I died upon you I didn't say it was oh
man don't do that I didn't say it was
safe
you knew I trusted you
what door that's your mistake graspers
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine
okay that's what I get for trusting what
dude you're actually a goddamn wizard
yeah I know right guys
hey what hey I mean I think that means
it can't be a death one cuz it's
occupying the center space you know I
mean you know oh my god how you guys do
that [ __ ] what the hell why did you let
that door closed
oh no no you're not you're not we
believe in you all the way all kinds of
dead we believe I know what we gotta do
you need bandages well I got some
bandages don't worry I'm totally fine
good good good work Bob coming for this
one I don't like ticket oh that's why
it's sticking that's wait whoa watch out
for solutions
I got a Gilmore one we're going through
yes yes oh my god I'm going I'm going
I'm going I'm going
what sport yes god this is it guys oh my
god what [ __ ] fresh hell is now dude
I don't know hey look a boot
everything's turning everything's
turning around and bandage this thing I
don't know what this thing is what is
this thing what is this thing what do
you mean you don't know what this is
okay please don't know why in the corner
right here and your boot was just like
no I did my god no harder
oh wait well wait I guess you can take
the music play
I just silence on my screen an awkward
wiggling oh I'm boogie
I that's really like thoroughly
underwhelming go back to main menu now I
can't just restart it this is it mark
your calendars everyone today's they
wave lives that everyone else doesn't
those never happens I climb at the Quinn
Wade wine stop with the anti-climactic
bull 3 anticlimactic is very climactic I
climaxed don't worry guys in turn of the
difficulty a little bit okay good give
us the hardest what is our artists
nightmare seven by seven by seven
nightmare cool good love it that last
one was six six six it was Satan but
this is nightmare this is seven six Lord
minion 777 right that's me Jana Reeves
777 you guys are naked no you're not you
look boots
I'm service did you get banned what did
you get banned where are we naked I
trust you implicitly
Wow Wow I thought it was just a 4-1 it
was the water one Oh God
is the quickest and I hate [ __ ] that
trusted you mark
you shouldn't have why would you do that
it's on nightmare mode I I trusted you
nightmare mode I trusted you implicitly
look at this you're not even taking the
bandages you're such a badass you didn't
[ __ ] found it give a [ __ ] hey Bob
guess who's alive
oh dude suck me out of my hole suck you
so you're welcome shoo behind you Bob if
you trust me implicitly you'll charge in
this next room for me I'm doing it
[ __ ] push the button yeah okay let's
do it yeah mark I trusted you mark it's
nanobots Oh No if I okay well that's not
good you better [ __ ] sing me a song
and glory I trust myself alive you have
to bring me back I can be the one to
trust you second [ __ ] hero
no no Garth so just gosh
Wade come on loser hurry up same-same
strat yeah
nice nice killer door I charge it okay
oh hell yeah this is how I do this is
how we do this is how we do this is how
we do oh yeah that looks soon are you
good you love it love it love it love it
love you how do you not get chopped into
15 bajillion pieces mark you're lagging
you're lacking you're lagging you're
lagging mark your literal no you're
you're sporting in place mark you look
at you oh look at you Chet oh boy what I
had a bad feeling about that room I'm
glad that we were lagging so that I
couldn't charge it oh my god wait where
are you wait just check in the corner
why aren't you with us oh sorry mark
that's okay maybe we shouldn't do that
strap it baby maybe caution safe it's
cool the corners not good don't go that
way
what why what's that Chicka Chicka
that's concerning the corners not the
way to go so I'm trying to tell you I
know that Chicka Chicka is terrifying
that's also not the way to go you throw
your shoe in there look where we started
my shoe it oh no that's not a good way
to die salute you robot guy or my daddy
yes oh please don't oh it's graspers Oh
mark take a door I think I my own door
okay you make your own door
oh wait Blazers oh I'm not picking that
door oh so much guys apparently south
way I have 20 health you got this I know
I know
oh I forty health actually goes not that
way can't wait can I don't all right I'm
gonna check out this room I guess I know
why it's raining rain bad
maybe it'll put you out or maybe it's
acid rain it's a success I feel not safe
windows 95 protect me
guys I've got the strats I think I'm
gonna go this way
yeah good good call good call on that
one yeah good call safety safety a good
solid cool cool cool neat mean is this
the alligator room yeah it is I just
make sure yeah you're good you're good
man the exits probably in the corner
right get that bandage I mean 20
Health's probably enough I don't know
okay all right man I'm just gonna do
this
and that's real quick
who's your [ __ ] hero now all right
okay wait what why well I guess fun
being dead garbage we had a system we
trust you okay I don't have a shoe yeah
yeah I have to health we all have
problems with I almost went in I almost
a few are gonna want to move right along
here it's got a shoe it's definitely not
deadly yeah it's so warm in this room
it's so hot like I am burning alive well
wait I clutched it up on the last floor
so it's on you now man Oh baby sleepy
it's so hot I think is me slipping into
the afterlife after my untimely demise
oh shoot I'm sure it's an explosion Oh
so it's so warm man I think I'm in Hell
I think what I died I I think I think I
went to hell I'm so hot I'm like there's
a really obvious and I'm so hot I'm
so please be the exit all right I need
that sweet big exit energy I'll give you
some big energy your respawning mark no
no I think it's just random his room
might have a respawn hey buddy how are
you doing oh I'm feeling a hundred
percent with two shoes wow that's great
man you incus yeah whatever it's almost
got your ass way the all the asses are
protections not so great mark Lyme
spines like what the [ __ ] i i don't care
get out of here bandage over here you go
away man all right I'm on my own okay I
guess wait mark could you check the
corner room for me yeah all right in the
chat what close love glove why do you
have condoms emotes they're not there
love gloves that's what connects a name
for condoms
no no it's a glove of love oh you can
say it's a glove for love oh god no I
thought that I thought it couldn't be
this way I thought it couldn't
I wanted to do hellos Wow
no it was very much not so fast it's
just it was one of those rooms where I
thought it couldn't get me like that
anyway marks very I'm dead
you can continue being hot now I'm so
hot
[Music]
I'm so warm I'm so warm I'm so warm it's
so hot in this room
[Music]
it's really high I was so uncomfortable
anyway don't go in that don't trust it
don't trust it by default I was killed
in a room that looked just like that
do not trust it I threw a shoe already
oh okay you're good then go for it my
only last go fourth day who what do I
care to die then oh [ __ ] do you add two
heads well you guys oh wait I didn't
even show it you guys died pathetically
hey I got it I got great literally not
even showing what was happening I was on
myself I was focused on me that's not
good that's gross
oh I got pants oh I love what you did is
even more concerning than the sound of
what there it is sorry I'm distracted by
the actual boob physics why are there
boob faces oh my god why is that the
boob physics they chose I don't know
that's just weird that's concerning and
I'm not gonna
that's not that's not how boobs or
physics works
[Music]